hallo liebe sport begeisterte
mitstreiter heute tag 4 des online
trainings steht ganz im zeichen des
militärischen es bei gary die nici und
ich dachte wir sind wieder da für euch
wir werden euch durch das programm
führen und die übungen vorzeigen
kontroll frage zu gestern ein bein stand
beim zähneputzen ist erledigt oder kann
man haken drunter machen wer es
vergessen hat dann am abend nachholen
dass man die sensomotorik nicht
vernachlässigen wir steigen ein in das
military fitnesstraining das heißt hohe
körperliche belastung intensives
aufwärmen vor gestaffelt und eine kurze
cool down phase zum schluss wir gehen
sahen wir beginnen mit laufen am stand
wir schauen dass man den kreislauf
wieder in schwung kriegen einfach einmal
30 sekunden lockeres laufen am stand das
programm generell heute wird sein nach
dem aufwärmen 30 sekunden
belastungsphase 30 sekunden bassist oder
erste trainings zyklus und danach gehen
wir in zwei durchgänge mit 20 sekunden
belastung und zehn sekunden pause hinein
das wird dann richtig intensiv also gut
aufwärmen gut vorbereiten
fünf sekunden auf und stehen bleiben
wir beginnen mit der heiß über seile zu
mobilisieren blick wendung nach links
blick wendung nach rechts im wechsel der
oberkörper bleibt ruhig das heißt er
rotiert mit die wendung kommt
tatsächlich aus der halswirbelsäule
dann gibt man den kopf nach links und
nach rechts jawohl wir schauen nach vor
und zurück
und wir bewegen den kopf von der linken
seite über die brust auf die rechte
seite und wieder zurück genau
jawohl wir bewegen uns wieder jetzt
startet mit dem hampelmann lockere
hampelmann sprünge und natürlich die
fleißigen zuseher und mit trainieren der
letzten tage wissen es bereits aber ich
wiederhole mich da gerne noch einmal so
die die heute erstmalig zu gestalten
sind wir sind täglich in der früh im
krankenrevier und lassen uns auf den
crooner virus testen und sind auch heute
wieder alle negativ gewesen
ok danke schön handel mal abgeschlossen
wir beginnen mit der schulter
mobilisation es aus armeekreisen
vorwärts auch dort kann man langsam
beginnen und das tempo dann langsam
irgendwo ein bisschen steigern
wir kreisen rückwärts schön die
beweglichkeit der schulter ausnutzen
genau wir geben die älteren seitlich
hoch und wir kreisen im unterarm wir
bewegen den ellbogen der virtuelle
belastet über liegestütze und sämtliche
bewegungen das heißt wir brauchen auch
die nach den schon aufgewärmt und
gelassen wieder am stand jetzt
selbständig immer wieder einen kniehoch
einbauen das heißt locker am stand
lassen knie zur brust richtung brust
ziehen linke seite wechseln rechte seite
wechseln
wir sind mitten im eigenen prozess
drinnen
danach kommt das spezifische aufwärmen
und dann fangen wir mit dem training an
ok nächste biegung handgelenke
mobilisieren das heißt wir greifen
zusammen und drehen das handgelenk der
kamera die richtung erfahren wir hin und
her wechseln
genau
jawohl dannheim ausschütteln wir drehen
den oberkörper das heißt wir wechseln
von der linken auf die rechte seite
können die hände als schwuler sie
mitnehmen mobilisieren entlang der
wirbelsäule auch für das heutige
training ganz wichtiger punkt okay wir
laufen mit anstand diese verwechseln hat
nicht dein knie hoch sondern das
anfassen das heißt die verse richtung
gesäß bringen
jeder dritte vierte fünfte schritt
schlägt die vier richtung gesäß hoch
erklärt dann drehen und drehen das heißt
kreisende bewegungen vom becken große
kreise genau da mehrere
rotationsbewegungen für fürs backen
drinnen dann machen wir das training der
vorbeuge kreideweiß schon voreilig und
das haben wir schon mit drinnen jetzt
haben wir es
genau und wir wechseln in den bocksaal
auf da können wir sagt ja wieder einmal
ab diese intensiver machen ihr hört von
mir ein kopf und ein stopp das heißt auf
ob schnelle bewegungen auf stop langsam
weiter bewegen
ganz kurz zu belastungen dass man das
ersteigern
ich habe meiner frau jenna stehenbleiben
wieder
wir bewegen jetzt noch das gelenk wir
kreisen das kniegelenk zum unterschied
zu gestern ja macht man es nicht mit den
beinen am boden sondern wir leben einmal
das linke bein hoch wir sind im einbein
stand konzentrieren einen punkt vorne
fixieren dass man sie ruhig stehen und
kreisen das nie gelenk punkt fixieren
genau richtung wechseln weil es das
gleichgewicht noch nicht ganz soweit
sind dass besucht so etwas zum anhalten
überhaupt kein problem seite wechseln
und die richtung wieder wechseln
einmal noch hinterland allgemeine
aufwärmen ist fast fertig dann manchmal
kurzen tempowechsel wieder steigern
schneller und langsamer
sie kennt den rhythmus an stoff genau
letztes gelernt was man jetzt noch
aufwärmen das sprunggelenk
wir haben wieder das linke bein hoch und
kreisen im sprunggelenk versuchen wieder
das gleichgewicht zu halten mit einem
punkt fixieren dann geht das
normalerweise sehr gut richtung wechseln
und seite wechseln
sehr gut allgemeiner teil haben wir mal
jetzt gehen wir in den spezifischen teil
des aufwärmens hinein
solltet ihr fragen haben zum aufwärmen
zum workout sportlich als natur
allgemein der doktor aus sitzt wieder
vorm pc und beantwortet die natürlich
gerne
damit ihr auch fachlich am neuesten
stand der dinge sei
wir beginnen mit der ersten übung den
mountain klein war das heißt liegestütz
ausgangsstellung und die knie dynamisch
richtung trost nach vor zu wenig gezeigt
dass gerne vorher gerne einmal frontal
seitlich geht schon los
und natürlich macht ihr mit ja also wenn
ihr erkannt haben sie die übung
funktioniert sofort die position
einnehmen und geht's los dann stehen wir
wieder auf 7 kniebeugen einmal tief
einmal halb tief das heißt der gehry
maxi halb die nici maxi positiv damit
man die unterschiedlichen varianten auch
wiedersehen geht schluss
wir haben zwar durch nächste variante
der tempolauf tempowechsel auf das heißt
ihr alle läuft am stand beginnt langsam
auf hopp so schnell wie möglich auf
stopp wieder normal weiterlaufen bitte
geht's los
stopp
genau
und wir gehen in die nächste übung
hinein der anleger steht sie im
liegestütz in den unterschiedlichsten
varianten die wir euch schon präsentiert
haben wir machen es jetzt eine ganz
normale standard liegestütz sie im stück
und los geht's wenn das ein bisschen zu
viel ist wie gesagt angelehnt an der
mauer angelehnt an einem sessel an einem
tisch ist alles möglich da sie im
siebten mal gleich raus dass wir die
bauchmuskulatur entsprechend vorbereiten
und 13a wieder dran denken ganz wichtig
die hände nicht hinter dem kopf
verschränken sondern die hände zur
schläfe geben vor der brust verschränken
oder in vorhalte je nach intensität
gerade etwas gerne hätte
sieben wiederholungen abgeschlossen dann
einfach aufstehen und wir gehen wieder
in den standort und diesmal etwas länger
dynamisch und schnell
hopp hopp hopp hopp
stock und stehen bleiben kurz
durchschnaufen durchatmen
wir nehmen nur zwei übungen dann sollte
man mit dem speziellen teil des
aufwärmens anschluss am ende angelangt
sein wenn man auch noch der ausfall
schritte weil wir es dann merkten im
werk hat die übung wird danach auch noch
in einer abgewandelten form zu sehen
sein und dann noch mal was für rücken ja
also einmal ausfallschritte bitte sie im
stück links sieben stück rechts wie ihr
euch leichter tut es mit nach vor
steigen oder mit zurücksteigen ist ganz
egal
nehmt euch eine variante sie mal links
und sieben mal rechts
ok dann bauchlage bitte die übung kennt
ja auch schon oberkörper aufrichten ist
aus der bauchlage füße lassen wir am
boden körperspannung aufbauen hintern
angespannt und oberkörper weg geben da
wiederum wichtig nicht mit dem schwung
arbeiten sondern mit der muskelkraft
arbeiten sind wiederholungen das bleibt
bestehen
wenn fertig wieder aufstehen einmal
manchmal noch den tempowechsel mit dem
lassen bereit und los geht's
hopp hopp hopp
ausschlafen ausschütteln kurz an schluck
trinken wer möchte wir haben den
spezifischen teil des auf wir haben uns
jetzt abgeschlossen das heißt jeder
scheute sich soweit fit und warm
aufgewärmt fühlen dass er jetzt für die
übungen für das workout bereit ist nick
bastel dir küste gut garrett war sehr
gut dann würde ich vorschlagen
wir gehen die erste übung am meer an die
ersten 30 sekunden zeigen wie es euch
vor erklären und die zweiten 30 sekunden
wird dann gearbeitet
erste übung der gesprungene liegestütze
garrett sagst du mal bitte vor volle
körperspannung volle konzentration und
geht's los jetzt hände und beine heben
sich loos vom boden körperspannung
bleibt danke gerne wir solch eine
kärntner sparen dann für das workout
nach dem aufwärmen vergeuden nicht geht
um auch das bitte angelehnt ich sage an
der mauer
wir haben auf dem podest es setzt es
geht auch im angelehnten zustand super
optimal wenn wir die vorschlag machen
wir uns bereit und starten wir in 20
sekunden mit dem ersten belastung durch
gang
die frequenz steuert ihr könnt es viele
wiederholungen offene grenze bei weniger
machen
wichtig ist dass es richtig dynamisch
ist okay sieben sekunden positionen
einnehmen
21 und los geht's
selbst als richtiger dynamik drinnen in
der bewegung und dieses exklusive
abstoßen dieses explosive arbeiten ist
ganz ganz wichtig das braucht der soldat
in sämtlichen bereichen von seinem
einsatz
wir werden es bei unterschiedlichsten
übungen dann sehen diese power exklusiv
entwickelt ist ein ganz wichtiger aspekt
der hauptsatz noch drei sekunden und
fertig die ersten 30 sekunden schon
richtig anstrengend gewesen deswegen ist
aber meister wirklich intensiver
aufgewärmt haben zweite übung der
ausfallschritt gerne machte variante
hände beim kopf mit gesprungenen wechsel
und die nie gemacht mit einer kurzen
zwischenlandung das ist keine nativ
nicht ganz so das problem das heißt dass
die etwas abgeschwächte variante aber
absolut in ordnung
fünf sekunden bereit machen wenn die
herzfrequenz und die atmung ist nicht
ganz runter kommt 21 und los geht's dann
ist es okay weil wir trainieren ja
15 sekunden halbzeit ist erreicht war
wieder wichtig beinachse kontrollieren
gerade sprunggelenk die hüfte muss
passen oberkörper aufrecht und 30
sekunden work hard time ist wieder
vorbei ist erledigt wir wechselt in eine
bauch übung ja das heißt rückenlage auf
der matte wir haben einerseits den käfer
als klassische prüfung die sehr intensiv
ist sie sagte ich dann der kleriker vor
und andererseits die cross cups dass wir
durch die nici vorzeichen dass fußsohlen
aneinander geht schloss hände überm kopf
nach vor typen hinter ablegen becken
heben das ist die eine variante
variante nummer zwei knie und ellbogen
schließen komplette streckung und wieder
schließen zeit geht lost 30 sekunden der
erkrankung weiter arbeiten
schöne dynamik in der bewegung je
schneller ist natürlich da hin und her
wechseln desto mehr belastung habe
wichtig ist dass wir immer wieder die
extremitäten arme und beine ausstrecken
zwischen drinnen da hinten spannend beim
hochdrücken von betten fußsohlen
geschlossen lassen
drei sekunden noch und zeit aus 30
sekunden vorbei letzte übung vierte
übung die machen sind dort bis und hobby
gestützt die nicht sagt euch die
variante 2 vor also runter gehen in die
libysche ausgangsstellung bei einer
dynamisch schließen und wieder hoch nahm
ein genauer braucht es kein liegestütz
zwischendrin dennoch nur die position
einnehmen und wieder hochkommen
die zweite variante der bürger auch mal
nur dazu dass es mit liegestütze hände
weg vom boden und hochspringen 30
sekunden arbeitszeit ab jetzt
halbzeit dieser reicht 15 sekunden noch
5 sekunden und zeit aus das waren jetzt
die vier übungen die werden uns jetzt da
in dem zirkel thema jetzt machen nachdem
tabata protokoll 20 sekunden belasten
zehn sekunden pause jede übung zweimal
diese durchgänge waren wir zwei mal
machen die werden uns jetzt wieder
verfolgen die belastungs zeit wird
weniger aber auch die brause wird
weniger ok es heißt es ist körperlich
richtig anstrengend richtig belastend
sei jetzt bereit nicke bereit immer sehr
gut das freut mich zu hören
das heißt wir starten mit 20 sekunden
gesprungenen liegestütz belastung in
zehn sekunden macht sich bereit geht es
in die position noch 54 position bitte
321 ort los gehts richtig dynamisch
abdrücken richtig dynamisch hoch kommen
20 sekunden volle power und ist jetzt
das ist kein kinder aus in das training
des anstrengend das hobby nicht zu viel
versprochen
definitiv das anstrengendste workout der
woche zwei sekunden 110 sekunden pause
position wechseln zwar trauma tief
durchschnaufen ausfallschritte
ausfallschritte zweite übung jetzt in
drei sekunden pause ist kurz und los
geht's
volle dynamik in der bewegung und immer
wieder die beinachse kontrollieren nicht
mit dem knie nach innen klippen oder
nach außen ausweichen
körperspannung bleibt 21 und base zehn
sekunden
das wasser bislang also kurze
positionswechsel zeit nächste übung
gründen lage der käfer oder die cross
cups und los geht's es ist schon fast
man zuschauen anstrengend magic circle
niki super hier macht das perfekt jeder
haben natürlich richtig gescheit gas
geben
optimal top 10 sekunden position
wechseln bird bis und hobby gestützt
drei sekunden nur bereit machen so eins
und los geht's wie gesagt im häuserkampf
beim überwinden von hindernissen diese
dynamik der bewegung die braucht das
ganz ganz dringend deswegen trainieren
wir sagt und wie gesagt das trainiert
man am besten in einen intensiven
workshop zehn sekunden positionswechsel
gesprungene liegestütz in fünf sekunden
drei zwei eins und los geht's
und solltet ihr während im training
darauf kommen dass die gewählte variante
die gewählte übungs variante vielleicht
doch bist du zu schwer ist nicht die
zeit streich verstreichen lassen und
pause machen so eine leichtere variante
nehmen ok drei sekunden 21 und aus
station ausfallschritte ist die nächste
drei sekunden 21 und gas geben da ist er
schon der erste schweiß fließt nach zehn
sekunden
nächste station der käfer oder die
krosse tabs 23 sekunden 21 und arbeiten
oder arbeiten werden auch lassen
vorletzte übungen im ersten satz im
ersten durchgang und versprochen wir
machen da eine kurze pause so dass er
bis zur luft kommen kennt das ist jetzt
noch mit scheint eine beißen 8 sekunden
und denkt daran was wir gesagt haben
meine strecken arme strecken 21 und 10
sekunden wechsel aufgehört ist und hock
liegestützen
21 es geht wieder los
letzte übung im ersten satz 20 sekunden
vor gas name es aussieht
jawohl gary hohes tempo frequenz gut
arbeiten fünf sekunden nur die letzten
fünf sekunden 2 12 minuten nach der
pause
durchschnaufen ausgehen an schluck
trinken aus lockern das ist jetzt der
zeit zwei minuten lang wie gesagt diese
art von training ist hochintensiv das
sieht man jeden tag trainieren das
reicht absolut das arme hinter wochen zu
machen
da anfänger vielleicht einmal in einem
rhythmus von allen 14 tagen das obwohl
intensive belastung hinein zu bringen
und die anderen trainings thema bis
jetzt gemacht haben einen rumpf kraft
zirkel ein kraft ausdauertraining des
cani täglich genauso machen sensomotorik
kann die täglich machen aber diese hoch
intensiven belastungen die bitte nicht
jeden tag machen überlastet sein körper
ja nie wie geht's dir war ganz schön
anstrengend richtig das denkmal das hat
auch sehr anstrengend ausgeschaut aber
jetzt aber wie gesagt zwei minuten pause
halbzeit von der pause haben wir gleich
das heißt eine gute minute ist nur zur
verfügung schluck trinken noch was geht
dir passt zu dir passt
okay okay das werde versuchen dass ihr
das dass ich dass man die zehn sekunden
in der mitte der 20 sekündigen belastung
noch unter teil vielleicht passt
vielleicht ganz gut dass die märkte zehn
sekunden vollgas wie gesagt acht runden
hormann acht mal 20 sekunden mit den
vier übungen und dann ist das workout
der intensive teil von heute vorbei ja
30 sekunden noch bitte aufstehen
kreislauf wieder ankurbeln wieder in
schwung kommen
klar geistig darauf vorbereiten was
passiert für übung wir fangen wieder an
so wie vorher mit dem gesprungenen
liegestütz ok volle dynamik in der
bewegung den sprung in die liegestütze
bakterium auch am boden die nici merz
angelehnt 13 sekunden gleich jetzt
wieder los positionen einnehmen
konzentrieren tief durchatmen sauerstoff
in den körper lassen auch während der
übung drei sekunden 21 und los geht's
zweiter durchgang
ich sage auch während den übungen atmen
ist ganz ganz wichtig der muskel gehört
mit sauerstoff versorgt und wenn die
luft einatmen dann kriegt der muskel
entsprechend net diesen sauerstoff dass
er arbeiten kann sich beim ersten
durchgang habe schon versandt die 20
sekunden sagen vor beide 10 sekunden
habe versand vielleicht schon fest beim
nächsten nächste übung ausfallschritte
drei sekunden bereit marken und geht's
los
oberkörper schon ausrichten
aber wie gesagt nicht hinterm kopf zehn
sekunden noch beinachse kontrollieren
321 horn pause sehen sie konnten
position wechseln in die buchung der
käfer oder die roswitha variante geht
das ganz ganz ganz 20 sekunden
jawohl schön das becken hochdrücken
hintern anspannen und dann wieder nach
vorgehen
und da war schön in die streckung und
wieder in die beuge halbzeit gut vorbei
und 20 sekunden aus zehn sekunden pause
vierte übung die birthers und die hog
liegestütz 21 uhr los geht's
schön aufrichten da gerade der kopf ist
immer in verlängerung der wirbelsäule
adobe diesen übungen schöne dynamik in
der bewegung 321 und wieder pause zehn
sekunden ersten vier übungen haben die
gleichen übungen machen wir es nur mal
und das training ist erledigt drei
sekunden position eins und los geht's
java volle dynamik wieder in der
bewegung den letzten zehn sekunden in
der übung liegestütz gesprungen
wir machen immer versprochen noch 53 und
aus kurzer wechsel in die
ausfallschritte fünf sekunden noch zeit
21 und los geht's wenn ihr fragen dazu
intensität steuerung habe sie gesagt
doktor ausschreibt und beantwortet
jederzeit halbzeit zehn sekunden
53 10 sekunden position für die
bauchmuskelübungen letztes mal den bauch
unter voller belastung los geht's
halbzeit beim bauch zehn sekunden auch
noch die dynamik einbringen in die
bewegung ja alles außer holen drei
sekunden 21 und jetzt die letzten 20
sekunden belastung mit burt bis und hock
liegestütz in drei sekunden 21 jährige
kommt bei seinen ich weiß eigentlich
schon zu hause ja gas geben 15 sekunden
nur noch zehn sekunden tempo hochhalten
tempo hoch halten
fünf vier drei zwei eins oder aus ja
alles sehr großer applaus von meiner
seite toll gemacht spitze gemacht jetzt
ein kurzes cooldown ausgehen am stand
gehen ein bisschen im kreis in der zu
hause in der wohnung gehen in ordnung
schauen wir dass man den kreislauf
kontrolliert wieder herunterfahren um
entsprechend da eine lasche regeneration
auch einleiten zu können
ein schluck trinken ja wieder gerne was
sagt was anstrengend ja sehr gut niki
sehr gut gleiches feedback war
anstrengend war cool genau das nun her
ich hoffe es hat euch genauso viel spaß
gemacht wie meinen zwei trainieren da
ich hätte gern mit trainiert aber ich
werde dann im anschluss natürlich
kleiner akku und sowie ihr wenn ihr
wollt es versäumt hat sie kennt
natürlich auf youtube jederzeit alle
trainings auch abrufen und entsprechend
anschauen jawohl
zusätzlich ermöglicht der auf die matte
atmet tief durch
ok legen wir den oberkörper nach hinten
ab und du mit ihm die kniegelenke die
beine nach links und nach rechts ganz
locker hin und her mit der atmung
mitgehen die wirbelsäule wiederum ein
bisserl mobilisieren entlasten die weit
unter dauerstress beim springen
genau das reicht das machen wir mal fünf
sechs sieben neue pro seite hin und her
ich sage die atmung wieder kontrolliert
sich langsam fährt wieder runter
ok stehe man noch mehr langsam auf
enorme ganz gemütlich den oberkörper
verdrehen auf die linke seite auf die
rechte seite kontrolliert seine atmung
schaut dass da wieder zu energie und zu
kräften kommt und nach jeder für sich 3
firma tief einatmen tief ausatmen in der
position wie er sie wohl fühlt in der
strecke position oder im normalen stehen
genau ausschütteln tief ein und ausatmen
ja wo leute intensives körperliches
workout militärisches haben wir
abgeschlossen jederzeit bereit wir
trainieren mit wir machen das am morgen
weiter und was sie so leiden kehrt ab
stadtmitte nächste woche noch mal voll
durch nachdem der lok tanja noch anhält
aber wir sind da wir trainieren mit euch
und morgen als auflockerung als
belohnung für die intensive harte
trainingswoche machen ein regeneratives
training mit aus denen mobilisieren und
regenerieren wir treibe freuen uns auf
euch morgen 10 uhr 30 danke von unserer
seite und top workout